we're old friends and we haven't seen
each other in a while
the last time we saw each other was with
you and your dear friend Donald yeah and
I put on these scrub onesies yeah this
onesie because we do a re-watch podcast
of of Scrubs which is very popular
like a hit yeah it's a podcast world
it's a huge hit all over the world and
so we made it a joke we made these like
onesies and and you put one on it was
amazing yeah I come to play and yeah we
have known each other for decades yeah a
long time a long time
um I watched your film yeah
whoa
whoa I think that means thank you
this is award level this is the real
deal this is an extraordinarily
beautiful
crafted acted directed shot holy cow oh
my God oh my God
while I'm talking about it are you
getting it's by the way it's called a
good person which
it will make you think so many things it
will make you feel so many things
um including
I mean let's just start with being alive
yeah loss yeah and how we deal with that
um I went through a lot of loss in the
last four years I lost my sister to an
aneurysm I lost my father to cancer and
then during covid one of my best friends
got covered and died it was well
publicized because he was a beloved
Broadway actor named Nick Cordero and he
was living in my guest house when he got
it and when he went to the hospital so
when I sat down in the pandemic in the
lockdown to finally write something uh
this is kind of what came out of me I
wanted to write about standing back up
after loss and trauma but in my
experience with some of these things I'm
sure I hope a lot of people can relate
when when there is a release when there
is a moment someone says something funny
you're just so happy that you have that
you can let the steam out of the engine
so I thought I want to design the movie
like that the movie is going to be about
grief and addiction and standing up
after trauma but I'm not going to make
it to model it I want there to be humor
in it I want there to be a release
because that's how I personally
experienced uh this stuff I remember I
remember memory of my family being in
the ICU waiting room just waiting to to
see what was happening with my sister
and my father said something that was
just mildly funny it wasn't even that
funny but we were we all just started
belly laughing with tears coming out of
her eyes because you know the human the
human mind and body want that release
they crave that release so that was sort
of like what was in my mind while I was
writing I mean it's watching this film
and and what she's going through the
great Florence Pew I think that's should
be just her name should change but how
about her performance yeah it's just
unbelievable she's very special why is
she so leap off of wherever she is and
like straight into our hearts and Minds
why are we all so obsessed with her
there's just a magic I mean it's the old
school thing of old school movie stars
where they had a magic obviously she's
beautiful obviously she's an incredible
actress but she has that magical thing
obviously you have it too these people
that that go to the next level and are
are movie stars and they um and they
just you can't take your eyes off of
them you cannot take this performance
from her I mean even though she's done
so much incredible work
even I who know her well I was just with
my jaw was on the floor with her
performance in this home and Morgan
Freeman also I must say because I had
directed him before in a comedy
I had the Comfort level with him and he
trusted me to really push him because
Morgan is a is a is a Gruff tough guy
and he can be intimidating um and I love
him to death but he's Morgan Freeman and
um and so I think because we've made a
comedy together he really trusted me and
let me push him and I think this is one
of the finest performances he's given in
a long time I agree and the two of them
together and I really felt that this was
an incredible emotionally compelling
Melting Pot of The Human Experience that
is the film you made the story you
wanted to tell and when you were writing
it were you like writing it for and with
Florence also tailoring it yeah we were
a couple at the time and we were in
lockdown together so I I really wanted
to write for her and it was great
because I would go down and write every
day and and then we'd come up and have
dinner and talk about I wouldn't let her
read it but we would chat about it and
I'd say you know today I kind of
discovered that this what do you think
about that and I was thinking that maybe
she does this and and it became she you
know she really became a we kind of were
developing it together
um each other's music yes we truly were
and she had this idea where she said I
think the character it would be great if
when we find her
um after uh there's a time Jump if we
find her and she's chopping off all her
hair and I said that's a great idea but
logistically we Shot the movie in 26
days I said logistically that's
impossible and she said you'll figure it
out and I said I talked to everyone
Florence you know should we shoot out of
or the movie completely out of order you
chopping off your hair is just not we
don't want to use wigs they don't look
real and she said you'll figure it out
so we eventually figured it out and um
and and it really you know that's just
an example of something that just came
out of her that was her idea she she
felt the character would do that and
it's really powerful and films she's
legitimately really cutting her hair off
and I love her look in the movie too
because it's different than her you know
fashionista red carpet Persona which is
so on point yeah she really well you
guys know that stuff I don't know she's
so into fashion oh my God she's so hot
it's like it's it's confusing she
confuses me to no end because she's so
talented and has so much Moxie she also
has so much bravado to be who she is
absolutely to say this is what I like
this is who I am no I don't accept that
from you yeah she's an incredible role
where does she get that from because I
am the opposite I'm like a
people-pleasing doormat in the best way
because I care so much how do I get some
of Florence Pew's straight I think she
has incredible parents uh just that
raised uh you know all all of their
children to be like Renaissance kids
they all play musics you know Florence
sing songs incredible musician of course
I was like of course
angel
s she and the songs that are in the
movie she actually wrote herself she
did
oh the origin story is her family
I mean to tell you that she loves
Charlie's Angels so much and that when
when she was young she would imitate all
of your fights seen she would like learn
your action sequences
I just texted her before it came on I'm
saying I'm doing Drew show she goes oh
my God will you please tell her that I
was obsessed with Charlie's Angels and I
know like her fight choreography
will you please text her back and tell
her that I believe her name should be
officially changed to the great Florence
I shall tell her yes okay that's an
exchange I can go to sleep happy with
all right well we have a clip here
actually take a look at the great
Florence Pew and Zach Braff
hey mama can you tell me where my pills
are which ones
we said we were going to wean off of
them remember did we yes because we are
in pain and we need more they're not
going to give you more Ali they have to
no they don't I need them
what's so incredible too is how
unobvious and nuanced you make
everything it took me a long time in the
best way to try to understand what's
going on with everybody thank you you
know what well we have to go to a
commercial break but the good news is
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you